i landed lex luthor at 26 years old
you landed uh barry allen flash at 23.
now i certainly wasn't mature enough to
carry a show at 23
let alone 26 let alone maybe just
recently i
i i'm able to maybe do that so when you
first find out you know i'm gonna play
this character
first of all were you like i much rather
play superman or
are there other characters that you'd
rather play because it's probably true
flash is probably not
top two or three on your list i mean i
used to grow up like arguing with one of
my best friends in high school who was a
big flash fan about about why superman
was
you know so much better than the flash
so it for sure wasn't
wouldn't have been like if i click like
had to pick a superhero at the time i
mean he's grown into being
one of my i mean probably up there with
superman now just because i'm so
emotionally attached
to the character now um but i don't
think i also
was you know at the time like i'd rather
play superman or batman because i'm not
i never even thought
i'd get to be any superhero right i'm
not necessarily like
you know isn't that the reality we don't
like like who had ever thought like
honestly i i never thought that i'd be
lex luthor let alone anything
right so i mean i'm sure like like you
were a talented guy you you did
a broadway tour you've acted your whole
life you've done all these things
you've had early success but uh
if somebody would have said to you when
you were even 23 before you ever got the
the script or even an eight as an 18
year old boy a little boy
hey you know you're going to be the
flash you'd be like yeah [ __ ] off
can you say [ __ ] yeah i mean i would
have been i wouldn't have believed that
ever been in denial about it for sure i
mean even
when i got the audition i didn't want to
go because i was like
i'm not going to get it and i get a lot
of audition anxiety
um and you know i if i if i i don't want
to waste my time or their time
the breakdown even was like 20 mid 20s
to early 30s or mid 20s to
early or to mid 30s again i was like 23
and looked like i was
19 maybe and uh i i didn't want to go
to the audition at all because i thought
it was so
irrational to think that i could book it
well you know that's exactly with me i
was like there's no way i'm playing lex
luthor no one's going to cast this guy
i'm i'm a i'm a i'm not a joke i'm kind
of a joke
look at me yeah my friends even said
that they're like
dude no and then you know what you know
what
you know what happened grant we [ __ ]
zoned in man
we turned we turned the volume up and we
proved wrong
oh man he did yours too right yeah he
did our pilot and he was in
my second audition i believe and he
called me after he had seen my tape my
initial issue with
uh david ravaport casting director
and really early on nutter was like
i want you to get this you're gonna get
this and that
from then on out i was like you know
tunnel vision honed in on
on getting it because he had this belief
in me that i was and it made me have
belief in myself
but like you already had some chops you
were still young
but at least do you think without that
theater background you'd ever be able to
make it through this
no no i mean i i i till still to this
day i mean
uh i i don't ever like even take my
sides to set
rarely i'm very like obsessed with like
the process of like
getting the scenes down and that's
definitely my theater background i mean
i i really
drill not just like memorizing it but
the scene work and it's not
you know hopefully i do much more
challenging stuff throughout my career
it's not like it's
nothing against the writers they do an
amazing job but it's not like it's the
most
in-depth like emotional actor work on a
regular basis but i take it really
really really seriously and
really prepared and um i did too it's
almost too much like i i i
i want to be too good almost i want to
like i don't want to
i worked so yeah i worked so hard that i
thought i'm like most people don't do
this they can't does anybody work this
hard
and that's obviously silly to think that
but i you know it was torturous actually
especially in the first seasons
like just trying to prove everybody like
i have to prove myself
and do you feel like you just want to
know these lines inside out you want to
just
be able to go on set and like it's a
play and let's go yeah i mean it's
i've come a long way with um
taking a little pressure off myself not
taking it as seriously at times i mean
i've never let up on the work
but i've i've always been really hard on
myself and i still
am um but i yeah i mean i've put
way too much pressure on myself early on
and got in my way a lot and i think my
it shows in my opinion at least in the
work like how like
wound up i was and how focused i was on
getting it right that you know
it gets in your way for sure